and we can't give too much away but  where is the Terminator when we find him  in this film Terminator is been you know  kind of around has been terminating  things about but also at the same time  he has lived now enough time with human  beings that he actually has acquired  some kind of human behaviour and you've  got a job I mean you've got a day job  the Terminator boy in order to  infiltrate and in order to be like to  blend in I am a drapery salesman a  logician a plumber anything no don't use  actually Jim Cameron's idea but I then  developed the character a little bit  more and improvised some of the lines to  the very funny it is very funny you will  horrible you beloved  [Music]